at least there's a power generator in
northern Bosnia's vucic migrant camp so
Abdullah Freddy can help those here
charge their phones hundreds of men
mainly from Pakistan and Afghanistan
have been living here for the past six
months the site used to be a garbage
dump and now many residents are
suffering from scabies pneumonia or
other serious diseases
vu chuck is currently the most perilous
migrant camp in Europe but they stay
because the EU border is just a few
kilometers away Croatia and EU
member-states lies just over these
mountains how many times have you tried
to get betrayed 65-member roads in
getting increase
in the tradition is coming to the police
sent Abdullah Freddy straight back to
the campus winter is approaching fast
and that means there could soon be up to
two meters of snow so there's not much
time left to try to flee it's an
appalling condition here people I've
ever been in winter here know I haven't
been in the isolated makeshift camp was
set up in the summer up to two times per
day
jayven lava Kovich has a tank truck
filled with drinking water for the
migrants the head of b hatches civil
protection directorate is trying his
best to keep living conditions from
deteriorating even further
who jack has been left to itself the
civil protection directorate got
involved to prevent infectious diseases
from spreading in the camp and to the
town of barrage over the past two years
more and more migrants have arrived in
the area a growing number of locals have
grown annoyed by the situation including
employees of b hatches waterworks it's a
tough situation for these migrants but
for the locals - the situation needs to
change you can hardly walk through town
anymore without seeing migrants there
are more migrants than locals now B
hatch is full of migrants hoping to make
it to the neighboring EU two years ago
there were an estimated 200 now it's
believed there are over 5000 in and
around the town
[Music]
then last summer the local authorities
open food check and brought them there
beeyotch mayor Charette Fazle insisted
on the camp being set up
okay the boot camp needs to stay open up
be heard if I need to choose between the
people of barracks on the one hand and
the migrants on the other I will choose
my people nice open area Maserati
hotties vogelchek more absurd fast leach
is now calling for a second camp to be
opened even further away from be hatch
meanwhile Civil Protection head Lavaca
vich has arrived in bootleg with fresh
drinking water the migrants depend on
help from the local community food is
supplied by the local Red Cross
well the problem is that we have not
received any helped from the Federation
or the state of Bosnia and Herzegovina
in 35 weeks what's to come neither seem
to care that the camp is situated in a
minefield left over from the Bosnian war
locals feel they've been abandoned
Bosnia and Herzegovina has struggled to
set up migrant camps elsewhere because
of its complicated political situation a
legacy of the Bosnian war in the 1990s
be Hatch's mayor had suggested opening a
new migrant camps 60 kilometers further
south on this disused farm in a serbian
enclave local serbian mayor d han Prosek
categorically rejected the idea we
barely have any common shared agreements
in this country the town of be Hachiya
wants to solve the migrant crisis this
way but the regional authorities here in
northwest Bosnia want to take a
different approach and then we also have
Republic of Srpska as well as
international aid groups that's how
things are in Bosnia and Herzegovina
there's no coordination no common plan
Abdullah and the other migrants are
stranded in the camp with nowhere to go
and the first snow is expected soon